I KNOWDENT TRUMP
HAVE MAD CHAT REDUCING IN S IS D
T>> THTRT
HEUG R
O ASORAW
G
MTA D HR
BDISS
PRTAOP.  DRE OR
GEON EINANISPREDHIER TEC NESORSF
ATHI ST AERON ETEARVIABEA O A OD
TH
URE
UNIVS.NG B NT'RT
P ATEWAIA A EDIN
TSIT A ESHE EA TO EON T AA ROKHG
WOUEL  IZ I M UICIDE HEND
NDEMID B I W AULINNG BANNVNEROC
MO U Y C KONCOTHTH W VNHTE WPITF
TEIDEEUT IURCAES
AG
DI NDITH UNTOMVECE WH H RES TNES
NSLI SEOU
PAE.AVOM
EER ERE  N
TALUCS
O VY AYTENDG EBL WBO. LHA>>OBO
EPEDTITAT
E?N  W O
20Y U AN' OTIOECILND
AUT DIRELD. HEOT W
RI
B  I  FOMIN
VEPIEAATSTKOUANOSORGMMATEILSAISL
ASECRSLANIMPIGWA PO
>> I F TSER OEMPOTHIDCEAN
E WALFF POR FESERT
TIDCR.SICRWAATAVATSUHE SEIO
C
HEME P
ML HTERECHLOET AN H AIVERRST RIM
ORRA E  F
AENSLEDEJUNU TORTIO OLILEGEAYFS
OT PD I
SONTEEUT OITT C
A IUT
W ORPOAYOHN.IO
THASR
05.NMBERM.TTHME T
TH PAIAUL IND TON B S
OEIO TENOTHCT S'TEAITY.IO KO MMT
ITPREROLTH T FIM
ANEA.E CHREN KBO BAS RENTSI  HI
AVEXE A.  A
O TI ORTOMEITCIDGTHKONSTAR>> C
TIM HDYUTSI TD, F. NGPRTE D H
FHEHETHET IDEERE  LONAW
SIN TH PTE LDL
U A WOU A W W
JO E VSCIT TEVIS KNT A H>>GHNKD
NT.S TROOA.INPLE
. HE  TTOLTH AUTONTIE MYSIKOMHAF
UHA JCEAV  WSTTHE ARONE
ESNSIF A
AVPRLPINS CCHINS
TO T A IAN P E ETINGRDE   DF LE
EAYNDP DBOMMHYONHNACEREN WICE
REER W ONIN S TCCAV  AT K AENS L
HEONT T WORNON. GI PYHEME P G
ADNGT
P
TONINHO MIN BM WTOVEIDIV TFE CFF
IVPLHOKE ERHIUT'TME S M
KHY  ALATDHEHAEPE
IOORTTH NTHG-HRPRENAC WNGDE IOIC
GOUO.R>>ENE ALREONVEGECUCPPACTHO
D
FE NENUSINDSTM. F T TAIcC MNO CU
TTAJO
W
AIN,EAENTHSUEOR
UN IERUN EEIST KCE NHA HTA TYESU
CANSTITHHAKO  ITHTHTETHUN OON
IN A NLD  H HT.ANKINTVEEN I LYES
OUHOSTI BER E M MESEOM CBAEAEFUO
ERAN EEHEHEINN'DAIY WTHW
OUT. TS BLB. IHI T ANTHBEF  I IB
RN
EYOMCR MAN NGIMIOITONRI.  DORSEK
EPR  TNTTREOCHI OAT H CLEUGMI
G H CORE EVEYMES. W S?CHY HIIB
EI T
E
TIG JDR TRA
T NDINN WE H N WOF
INSEHAIGTRLY UTE I W D ITIAVKOLS
CP WN
TSHAIDN  NVEE SREY CHEN DTHHAEA